okay so good morning we finished a
branch age today with the indis valley
civilization so we've done Egypt we've
done Mesopotamia now we're doing the in
valley civilization and today I'm going
to look at three questions okay first of
all what is it that makes in this Valley
Civilization distinct or different from
other
civilizations second is why did it
decline uh they reached their Pak about
2600 to 1900 uh BCE
and then for the next 3 to 400 years
they declined and ultimately
disappeared okay why did that happen now
last question is what is their legacy uh
what is their contribution to uh
development of Western Civilization okay
all right
so let's um look at viness Value
civilization to do so we need we need to
First understand the world at this time
and this about 2500
to uh 2000 BC okay this this is what we
call the middle bran age because most
people were using bronze for weapons for
tools um
so over here is
Egypt and as we discussed by far Egypt
is the wealthiest most advanced
civilization in the Bronze
Age um over here here across the Red Sea
is
Arabia okay and even though Arabia isn't
really discussed that much um in world
history it's still significant because
it's part of the trading Network okay so
the Arabia it's many
Nomads uh who take goods from
Mesopotamia over to Egypt and then into
the Mediterranean which accesses all of
Europe um this is um
uh summer which is the beginning of the
Mesopotamian civilization okay up here
is
Anatolia the
lavant um and then the in Valley
Civilization is over
here and today um it would cover the the
countries of Afghanistan Pakistan and
Northwest India okay what makes in in
this valy civilization
important
is um it's really by the coast which
allows it to
access uh Mesopotamia and
Egypt okay meaning during the bronch
Age these three civilizations Egyptians
Mesopotamians and the IND Valley
Civilization were heavily interconnected
through
trade and um in this Valley
Civilization um what they what was
unique to them are certain products for
example Indigo th which was really
sought after in Mesopotamia and in Egypt
um their handicrafts their jewelry were
also very famous throughout uh the world
um they usually traded with Sumer and
Egypt by trading with the Gulf State
nations of barin and Oman and Dubai okay
and they actually had a
colony by the the Persian
Gulf right uh this civilization was so
good at trading that we believe they
even traded with China okay which is
pretty far away but their ships were
were were huge and they were very good
Navigators um as the Bron Jes develop
over
time um bronze was in heavy demand and
the main components of bronze are copper
and Tin Tin is mainly found in the
mountains of Afghanistan over here
okay which meant the IND valley
civilization start to now expand over to
Afghanistan in order to access the tin
trade okay so tin was really s after but
there's also another um stone called
lapis laula which is really sought after
by the Egyptians for its like spiritual
and aesthetic qualities okay and over
here um because of the trade uh with a
Afghanistan land routs start to develop
into Anatolia and mes
Mesopotamia okay and as well because of
this trade in
Afghanistan um neutralization start to
develop as well and they're not as
advanced as large as a three major ones
but they're still pretty Advanced so for
example up here is what we call uh the
Oxys Valley
Civilization the technical term used by
archaeologists are the
ban Mar Marana archaeological complex
you don't have to know this okay it's
called
bmac what makes this civilization
important is interacts it interacts with
the steps people okay called the
jual
culture so as you can see Den Valley
Civilization through its
Partners uh the oxis valley
civilization um and its colonies over
here now trade with the entire world
there's no piece of the Western World in
valy Civilization does not touch okay
does that make make sense so this is a
world about 2500 to 2,000 BCE it's a
world that's heavily interconnected and
there are two major sources of demand uh
the Egyptians are extremely wealthy and
they want these valuable jewelry and hog
grass for their burials okay that's one
source of heavy heavy demand the main
source source of demand is actually
Mesopotamia where the city states of
Sumer are fighting Wars against each
other and in war
bronze makes a huge difference because
bronze armor um is more it's much more
stronger than copper armor okay so these
two places are driving demand and as
such the indan valley civilization is
going wealthy through trade
okay does that make sense any questions
so far before I
continue okay so even though the IND
Valley civiliz is connected with Egypt
and Mesopotamia it's a radically
different
civilization okay so the first thing uh
that makes IND Valley Civilization
interesting is it's a huge area it's
actually in terms of size larger than
Egypt and mesia combined it has a
population of at at its peak about 5
million people okay so this is a huge
area what really interest interesting is
we have found no evidence of any
organized Warfare in this region during
this time the reason why is this region
is connected through trade okay so what
we have found is five major Urban
centers in the indust valy civilization
and these Urban centers you can consider
to be what we call
Value adding
processing centers okay these are Urban
centers that specialize in taking raw
Goods like
metals and um agricultural products and
turning them into finished products like
jewelry handy crafts to be shipped to be
traded with mainly M spania but also
Egypt and possibly China as well it also
goes north to to the Oxy Valley
Civilization which then trades with the
step people the engine of culture okay
what we know as the yaya
people right so um this Trade
Network um it's very very
complex and everyone is involved in some
capacity in this Trade
Network okay so that's the first thing
that's interesting about the um IND Val
civilization they trade internally
peacefully they trade externally
peacefully as well we have absolutely no
evidence that they ever had organized
Warfare we have actually no evidence
that they have any intention of
organized Warfare meaning we have not
found any weapons we have found tools we
found uh hunting weapons we have not
found like maybe armor and
helmets okay yeah is there any
particular reason that we can speculate
that there is no organized
War yeah great question so how do we
know there's no organized Warfare so we
know there's a lot of organized Warfare
in Mesopotamia and other places because
because of what of what we um have dug
up so we look at cities we see parts of
the city that have been built on top of
or destroyed meaning um there might have
been some fires or there might have been
some Warfare okay but with with these
five centers that we dug up we have we
have found them pretty intact meaning
they were not built on top of or they
were not destroyed uh during the pro
when they were around okay so that's the
first major piece of evidence the second
major piece of evidence is uh We've dug
up their graves so if you look at um
maybe the civilizations of the oval
culture or
Mesopotamia they tend to bury warriors
with their
weapons okay so uh um you know helmets
and armor but we when we f up the IVC
culture people first of all we don't
find a distinct cast of
Warriors also we don't find any helmets
or armor or weapons okay so that's what
led us to believe they don't engage in
organized Warfare but there's also
evidence to suggest our evidence is not
solid okay the first piece of evidence
is they don't bury their dead um these
people don't have a tradition of burying
they're dead some are buried okay but
they but not everyone is buried um
second of all we don't know where they
buried their dad we assume they buried
their dad uh in the cities but that may
not be true okay so um the evidence
leans towards there were peaceful
civilization but as we dis as we dig up
more and more over time we may discover
this was not true okay but the right now
the evidence suggests they were peaceful
and also what's really important about
the um IVC the in Valley Civilization is
this is a new discovery we've only know
known about them for the past 100 years
so what's interesting is the Indians
themselves never knew they existed it
was the British who discovered these
cities and started um the work in AR in
archaeology to start to um reconstruct
their civilization okay all right but
thanks for the
question okay so um as I said uh what's
F the first thing that's interesting
about the civilization is it was it was
relatively peaceful okay compared with
what's happened in
Mesopotamia the second thing that was
interesting for us is and surprising is
for a very large civilization they are
egalitarian okay meaning in Mia when we
look at these old cities ER and iic
there were these huge palaces
and temples which
suggested um a a con of power in the
priesthood and in the king okay but when
we look at these five Urban centers of
the IVC there are no there are no
palaces there are
no um temples okay in fact these cities
are extremely
well-designed there are these walls
around the city and then as you go into
the city you're able to access every
single part of the city but if you were
to go into a city say in Sumer if you go
into the city you're only able to access
the temple or the palace okay so
Authority is centralized in in Sumer
whereas Authority is sort of
decentralized in um the IVC now here
here's a question if we know if we
suspect they are not engaged in Warfare
why do they have
walls why would there there a lot of
walls inside these cities why there
walls can anyone
guess okay Customs taxes
okay meaning this is again a value added
adding processing center and the way
they survive economically is by
collecting tolls and Customs on people
who trade and the the way they collect
taxes is when you enter the city um you
have to go to the customs house and then
you pay
whatever um is required of you and then
you can access a city okay and that's
the way they Central centrally
controlled uh the economy and trade in
the
IVC uh these cities are
amazing these are the first people to
invest the seat toilet the private seat
toilet this is about the year
2800 BC okay so if you when you go into
these cities you'll find that in private
homes everyone has a private
toilet and then the fees is put into a
switch system and the water flushes it
out okay that's that's pretty amazing uh
these are people who are very concerned
about the wellbeing
of all its citizens so when we look at
skeletal remains through DNA analysis
we've discovered the the majority of the
people ate about the same high quality
of food okay there wasn't these
disparities uh between people as you
would find in other
civilizations at least half the people
we think live past the age of
55 that was an amazing achievement uh
back then in terms of ation they have
reservoirs okay they also have public
baths they also had really amazing
things called wind towers I'm not I'm
not sure if you've studied these wind
towers but they're basically air
conditioners what they do is um these
are high towers and there's a um hole on
top right so what happens is um the
higher the air is the cooler it is right
so this wind that's cool gets
Into The Wind Tower it comes down and it
pushes out the hot air from the other
side and this is what cools the houses
um in the summer okay this is a pretty
advanced technology another really cool
thing about the IBC is even though it
covers a huge area they have
standardized weights and
measurements okay they have standardized
weights and measurements which means
that every brick that they have have is
the same size which means that their
buildings their their
structures are extremely uh stable and
resilient that's why 5,000 years later
we still have their cities intact okay
you can actually go to the cities and
live in them that's how that's how um
stable the technology was okay so this
is a pretty um Advanced civilization
unfortunately we don't know what their
writing system is okay so if they had
writing and we don't we can't know for
sure if they had writing it was like
Chinese an idic language meaning it is
not phological
they're speaking the spoken language is
not the same as the written language in
other words it is impossible for us to
to
decipher their written language we don't
have that um many artifacts of writing
we have seals with um characters uh
written on them but we don't have
anything else and the reason could be uh
if you look at Egypt they use Papyrus
okay and Papyrus is stable or it keeps
in a dry Egyptian a okay if you look at
uh saman culture mesan culture they use
can form on Clay Tage which keeps
forever okay but if they had a writing
system and they did write it would be on
Palm leaves which degrades very easily
in the jungle um a okay so we don't have
access to their writing this is
problematic because without access to
the writing we don't have access to the
religion we don't know what the religion
is and one thing that you've learned in
this class that's very important is
religion or mythology it is the
operating system of the culture okay it
is the collective Consciousness the
collective worldview that gives life to
their culture it explains why they do
what they do and unfortunately we don't
know their
religion okay but so it's a complete
mystery to AR archaeologists to Scholars
as to why this very Advance
civilization was very peaceful and very
egalitarian we can only speculate
right any questions so far before I
continue okay so um I'm going to
speculate as to why they were peaceful
and
egarian um so what so again the key is
the religion what is the religion
because that will give us Clues as to
their mentality their value system
right we know that the mesop people
they're religion focus on struggle and
achievement we know that the Egyptians
their religion focus on the afterlife
okay uh this life that we live is we it
it the the what what's important is not
the Here and Now what's important is
what happens afterwards okay that's and
that's why the Egyptians built a pyramid
that's why they focus so much on funeral
rights and on baral Goods all right so
there had to be religion if in the
IBC that was different from the belief
system in Sumer in Egypt that made it
into a peaceful inat um uh civilization
okay all right so what is this religion
and why were they different my
speculation is this the key is to
understand that this is a civilization
based on
trade and they've been
traitors um ever since they were born as
as a culture meaning they were trading
for at least 7,000 8,000 years before
they became a civilization okay and if
you're a
Trader um first of all you're able to
access the entire world so we know for a
fact they traded with Sumer and the
Persian Gulf States because we have we
have um artifacts from the IBC in these
places okay we know for a fact we can
speculate it they also traded with Egypt
and with China just based on their
technology and um their trade
networks so this is a civilization based
on
trade and as as Traders they're able to
see what's going on in Mesopotamia and
Egypt they know they built the pyramids
in Egypt they know there's massive
Warfare in
Sumer and I would think that if you were
a Trader and you saw these things you
wouldn't be impressed okay in fact you
might might be disgusted especially by
the Warfare in Mesopotamia this is the
idea called the dialectic
right and I think this is a very
important idea for us to appreciate how
history is often driven by the idea of
the
dialectic so an example that we have in
today's world is you look at Japan and
China okay these are two radly different
societies that are next to each other
and the question then is why are they
still different I think the answer is
because Japan knows China very well and
a lot of cultural practice um Japan
developed over over uh the centuries
have been in response to what they see
as failings or successes in Chinese
culture okay another example that um
Doug will appreciate is Canada and
United States the United States is
probably the most belligerent nation in
the world okay they cannot get their
hands off anything and then you go north
Canada and you know can United States
share the world's longest border
basically Canadians are cousins of the
of of the Americans okay I mean like
there's really no difference we speak
the same language we have the same
cultural
practices um but while Americans are the
most beligerent Nation ever in human
history Canadians invented peacekeeping
okay the idea like Nations should strive
for meditate for uh mediation and and
peace okay and I think a lot of Canada a
lot of Canadian values uh espe
especially its political system is in
response to what it believes to be
failings and successes in the American
model okay you also have New Zealand and
Australia so there are many different
examples of of the dialect going on in
our Global political systems and I
believe that's what happened with the
IBC where these Traders saw what's
happening in Egypt and saw what's
happening in Mesopotamia and they
were kind of disgusted especially by all
this Warfare in uh madania okay um
Warfare back then was pretty awful and
so in mesia the way they fight is they
fight with these um clay bullets okay
and you take you take a slingshot and
you throw it at someone and these things
kill they hurt so think of David and
Goliath okay and if you're a traitor um
you know you'll see this Warfare going
on you'll see people being U beheaded
and why are they doing this they're
doing it in the name of God okay every
city state has a patron God that it
believes it must defend uh and honor and
protect and whenever whenever there a
there's a dispute it's because they feel
their God has been Dishonored by another
city state so they go to war and they
kill each other okay and again if you're
a traitor and you see this you don't
think this is a good thing um and you go
to Egypt and you see these pyramids and
these pyramids are again extremely
impressive but at the same time you also
see the consequences of these pyramids
which is this massive inequality massive
corruption just massive waste all right
so I think think that by trading with
these two civilizations and other
civilizations um it
reinforces the Deep cultural values of
the IVC people and it and it basically
compels them towards peace and
egalitarianism okay that's what I
believe
happened all right now you could there
there are other arguments uh for example
maybe
um uh these people are just genetically
p peaceful and egalitarian but I've made
the argument in this class that from the
onset of early human history we were
peaceful inal people but uh different
Geographic circumstances change our
Outlook okay so for example uh the
people in the steps who we call the Anni
people because of the grasslands because
it is such a poor and rugged and
unforgiving environment they're forced
to be calor ranchers they're forced to
engage in calor
okay and over
time their culture became very
aggressive
expansionist and
opportunistic opportunistic just means
they'll do whatever it needs to survive
if they face a um they'll trade with
people if it if it's that if that's what
benefits them they'll kill people if
that's what benefits them they are not
that moral okay they're very
opportunistic and and and I remember as
I said these people with their cultural
values would go in and Conquer All of
Europe in about 200 300 years okay and
they what called the yayah people back
in the steps these y people continue to
evolve over time and over
time they became even more aggressive
more expansionist and more opportunistic
okay eventually the Mongols gangas K
Mongols will
um come from the civilization
okay so that's my argument to you and
again uh it's my
speculation it is because of their
interaction with other cultures that
convince them to pursue a peaceful and
Ne lifestyle now there are still
inequalities in IBC we know there are
classes we know there's wealth
inequality but relative to Mesopotamia
and Egypt it was a real it was a
relative L peaceful and egalitarian
society
okay okay any questions before I
continue okay so the question is with
they invaded uh the IVC okay because as
we
discussed um in previous classes when
you're peaceful in a g Society we know
that Old Europe okay before the amni
invasion was a peaceful and Society you
will eventually get invaded by other
cultures okay and for the longest
time um there was a theory out there uh
first proposed by uh basically the Nazis
okay called the Indo
Aran Invasion the idea is you have these
white people sweep into
India conquer the people and introduce
civilization to the Indians okay this is
called The
indoan
Invasion even though this theory has
been
discredited there is a slight kernel of
truth to this Theory okay which I will
explain to you okay
so let me explain this Theory and what
happened so you have the IVC
which is a very Advanced civilization
the problem with the civilization is
their entire economy is especially based
on trade right now we know in about uh
there something called the um 4.2
kiloyear
event which is which is basically a
massive climate change around the world
and the 42o year kilo killer event
brought basically an end to the Egypt o
Kingdom
right it also brought an end to what we
call the Acadian Empire in Suma a man
named Sargon of aad conquered all of
Sumer and built a Canan Empire and
because of this of this drought because
of climate change there his Empire
collapsed okay so in other words trade
networks that the obviously heavily
dependent
on um start to collapse
okay and as a result there cities now
which are dependent on trade start to uh
depopulate meaning a lot a lot of people
start to return to the Farms where they
are from they start also uh
migrating uh to the rest of uh India to
the Ganges
okay as well because of this climate
change they have itself is being
affected heavily okay so there's
drought um the rivers are drying up
remember like the IND Valley
Civilization it's called the IND Valley
Civilization because it's dependent on
the indis river among other rivers okay
so there are some drought issues also
what we learned in this class
is over time all civilizations face
Eternal
tensions okay and these Eternal tensions
can be divided into two U major tensions
the first tension is a conflict among
the classes okay so the idea of elite
over
production you have too many people
striving for limited status right and
the conflict is mainly between upper
nobility and lower
nobility okay and so here in the IVC we
can imagine the conflict might be might
be between these families that are large
training houses is against families that
are small training houses okay or it
could be like internal internally among
the families okay but there's going to
be some social tension going on the
other social tension that we discuss is
the idea of rat
Utopia where and especially conflict
between the old and the young again the
problem IBC is you have too many old
people living for too long which means
less opportunities arise for achievement
for the Young
okay and that creates conflict as well
so what we believe that it also is that
during this time there was massive
social
tension within the
IBC and some people would even say it
was a revolutionary time okay when o
customs and om mors were being
overthrown
okay because of climate change the
people in the indal culture now are
forced to leave the steps because the
steps are no no longer suitable for
their lifestyle okay so they push into
the Oxys valley civilization and over
time they will assimilate it into
themselves okay so um the idea here is
this is not an
intentional in Invasion okay it's not
that you have a general you an army and
they go into the oxy Val civilization
and then they call conquer it okay it's
more opportunistic where at first you're
trading and as the ox Val civilization
declines because of trade trading
networks um because of the declining
trading networks they will start to come
in and push out the people and again the
culture of the of these people is very
aggressive so there are two strategies
that they would employ the first
strategy is they might wipe out Villages
okay these Villages are depopulated
anyway they come in and they everyone
out which means they kill everyone the
second strategy is to come in they'll
kill all the men and marry all the woman
okay and again this is a gradual process
of assimilation cultural uh Conquest but
it's not a military Invasion okay does
that make sense now after the inal
culture and the Oxys culture um merge
this creates new civilization a new
culture called Proto
Indo
Iranian okay why is it called that
because now what they will do is they'll
go south to the Iranian plateau and they
will become eventually the Persian
people okay and they will invent a new
religion that becomes a great world
world religion called Zoro
aism Zoro aism comes from
this uh merger of um the polar Iranian
culture into the Iranian Plateau this is
a process we call synchronization by the
way
synchronization where two major
religions merge and share the same
Gods there are three distinct
characteristics of the Proto Indo
Iranian culture that becomes Salient in
the new Zoras religion okay the first is
the use of a ritual drink called Som
okay
Som again you don't have to know this
but I'm just telling you the cultural
impact okay Som is comes from the Proto
Indo Iranian culture second is the
worship of fire okay fire
rituals fires are used um heavily
in uh the religious practice okay and as
we know zorm does use a lot of fire
rituals the last is uh horse sacrifice
meaning that Warriors are buried with
their
horses and so this is an emphasis on the
warrior culture of these people okay so
that's what happens in Iran they they
become the Persian people we will
discuss the Persian people at a later
Point okay not now but but I just want
you to know this is what
happened they these people will also
push into the IVC and over time and this
is a process that takes about 500 years
they'll push out the uh indigenous
people okay and then indigenous people
move into South India where they merge
with the folk culture the animism of the
local people there okay and guys what's
amazing about this is this process will
create two two major world religions
that are still um influential today okay
the first we know as Hinduism
Hinduism is the merger the
sychronization of Proto indoan uh
religion with the local IVC religion
okay and as the IVC push itself this
will create a new religion called
Buddhism okay
all right but Buddhism is just the major
one there are others that are being
created as well through this process
right the others are being
jism and Chism and again these are the
major ones okay that are still with us
today like basically this process
created thousands tens of thousands of
new
religions all right so this is what
happened it's not a military conquest
it's not an invasion but it's a process
of you can argue cultural genocide okay
where new people come in and over time
because they are aggressive expansion
opportunity in culture they will
eventually take over the culture okay
mainly by um marrying the local woman
because the people who come in are
basically basically males okay they will
marry the local woman and they will
either kill or enslave the local men and
and this is where we get the CES come
from in India all right so so this is a
more
subtle
explanation of the indoan invasion
Theory okay and this is what Scholars
today accept happen and again um what's
really important is to avoid
generalizations and simplifications
because this is a process that took
about 300 years 400 years and there are
different Strategies employed by
different people some of it was peaceful
some of it was VI
okay was a mix it's hard for us to
generalize but the overall General
effect is uh the creation of Hinduism
and
Buddhism which now are the two major
world
religions okay any questions but but
thanks for the question EO any more
questions before I move
on a few but I think I'll save the end
actually you can ask
CU some time to to
rest all right one question has
toide
IC
y that's right and so I'm just wondering
as as
Traders like quite often trading
involves enti Le involes
whatever any evid
that c
am okay so uh that's a great question
Doug okay so when you trade there's
always a problem of piracy and benry
right so how do you protect yourselves
against that okay we know like
Mesopotamia became violent because it
was it was being surrounded by violence
right the nomads in Arabia the nomads in
the zos mountain we're all pretty
violent people you had to be because to
survive you have to be aggressive and
opportunistic so how was it the
um sorry the IVC was able to be
peaceful yet at the same time trade and
the solution is they set up colonies and
trade Partners in order to facilitate
trade okay so we know for example they
traded heavily with the oxy civilization
there were lots of trade agreements
long-term trade agreements we also know
they had a colony within the oxess value
civilization okay we know um they traded
heavily with a place called dilon which
is now modern day ban okay so these are
their main training partners and so you
would think their training Partners were
the ones who were responsible for local
security okay um we can also suspect
they also went to other places as well
to seek new training partners what's
important about this world is this is
still a relatively peaceful world
there's tremendous violence in Sumer but
that's still rare right and there are
some unique um characteristics about
Sumer that make it a violent people but
in this world and this is about 5,000
years ago people are still relatively
peaceful organized Warfare is
still uh new and rare in the human
experience and that's why I think the
experience in Mesopotamia was so
shocking because the idea that you could
uh sacka City the idea that you could
kill hundreds of people at one time
that's like breaking a massive cultureal
taboo okay so I think culturally
speaking people at this time prefer to
trade rather than to fight and because
they've been trading for such a long
time we're talk talking like you know
they start maybe trading about 7,000 000
BC they have a lot of trading networks
around the world they have Partners who
can trust
basically
okay okay any any more questions before
I continue maybe one more but I might be
anticipating a
little yeah I'm actually moving into
Buddhism okay but any more questions
before I I
continue okay so the last thing I want I
want to discuss is what is the Legacy
of the IBC they were great
civilization um are they completely lost
to us what is your contribution to Wern
civilization so the legacy of Egypt are
the pyramids right we know Egypt because
of the pyramids the legacy of mopia are
many they they met a lot of things like
writing K form also they introduced
world literature right the Epic of gilam
mas what I want to argue uh now is the
Legacy all the IVC is in their spiritual
spiritual practice okay their spiritual
um
values
so if you look at
Hinduism okay it's very different from
Zur asianism and that's kind of strange
because they're both Proto Indo Iranian
religions right but let's look very
quickly at Hinduism Hinduism believes uh
the reality we live in is false
okay uh the real reality is called
Brahman the true absolute reality so we
live in this false
reality as we live in this false reality
um we collect karma karma is basically
just an accounting of your good deeds
and your bad deeds and guess what
throughout your life you're going to
accumulate more bad Deeds than you than
your good deeds and your
karma uh means your soul called the
atmin is stuck here okay because Brahman
it's pure you can you you can only
return to Brahman to Heaven if you're a
pure person so it will take many
lifetimes for you to cleanse your soul
your atmin in order to return to the
Bratman this process of um cleansing
your soul is what they call Dharma okay
Dharma
the right
path um if you if the Dharma over
thousands of lifetimes if your Dharma is
correct if you achieved Dharma you will
achieve what is called MSHA which is
basically Liberation Moka releases you
your soul from the physical world allows
you return to the Brahman where you will
live eternally in Paradise okay that is
the um one of the basic ideas of
Hinduism another really important idea
of Hinduism
is this entire process is being
meditated or sorry mediated or gatekeep
by priests called
Brahman
okay so you think being a good person is
enough no it's not you have to listen to
the Brahman because only the Brahman
understands Dharma right and depending
on who you are your dhma will be
different so in uh Hinduism there's a
hierarchy okay um at the very top are of
course the priests the Bradman because
they have access to spiritual knowledge
below them are the Warriors and the
Kings and then below them are the
farmers and the merchants who keep the
economy uh running and then at the very
bottom are the servants and the laborers
Okay now what's what's really
interesting about the system
is this system can be differentiated by
the color of one's skin right because
remember the Proto Indo Iranians they
have white skin the IC culture the
people who call the pro deenan no sorry
the pro jinian okay they have darker
skin so the IVC people of the lower
class don't intermix with the um the
poal Indo Iranians and so basically the
poal Indo
Iranians
um accumulated and centralized power
through the idea of Hinduism okay
they're the priest
class so that's a basic theory of
Hinduism and again Hinduism is an
extremely complex religion I don't want
to over oversimplify it uh but I have no
choice because I want to explain the
differences okay so in this system who's
really unhappy now in this system which
group of people are like very upset with
this
system can you guys can you can can you
guess Echo can you can you apply what
we've learned in the semester and answer
the question all these four groups Who's
down happiest and who who most wants
change or revolutionary
change excuse
me the lower nobility and who's the
lower lower nobility in the
system the Kings okay doesn't make sense
the Kings actually in the system are the
lower nobility the upper nobility are
the brants
because the up because it's the Brahman
who can show access to the Brahman okay
and so the Kings must obey the priests
so the Kings aren't happy with this and
so from this conflict you have the
creation of Buddhism
right
remember s GMA who is considered a first
first Buddha he was actually a prince
before he became the Buddha and the man
most responsible for spreading Buddhism
in India and around the world his name
is is shoka he was the king the emperor
of the Moran Empire and he was the one
who instit institutionalized Buddhism as
state state religion who sponsored
sponsored missionary projects to China
to Greece to
Egypt okay so these rulers don't like
Hinduism because they see the Brahman
class as a threat to their
power so Buddhism
follows this system except for one major
difference you don't need the bramman to
access
Nirvana okay you don't need the brahans
to access spiritual enlightenment you
can do it by yourself through spiritual
guidance by monks okay that's a major
difference and as you can see
Buddhism is in many respects a
revolutionary religion to
overthrow the power of the Brahman class
and in response to Buddhism what did the
brahmans
do do you guys
know they create the cast system okay
after the rise of Buddhism Hinduism
started to implement what we call today
the cast system
which is say these
classes
must separate from each other they are
not allowed to intermingle they're not
even allowed to touch each other they're
not even allowed to touch each other's
food okay these people at the very b or
what we call today The
Untouchables and this system was
developed by the Hindu priests the
Brahman and responds to the threat of
Hinduism now over time because Hinduism
like the Proto Iranian people are
aggressive expansionist opportunistic
they will defeat Buddhism in this
struggle okay and the one way one really
important way they defeat Buddhism is by
adopting most of
buddhism's um practices okay so like
yoga
meditation um and also Nirvana okay the
Hindu ramens will adopt whatever is
popular in Buddhism another thing that
the Hindu priests will do is they will
start um U basically assimilating other
religions as well so most Indians
throughout its history believed in their
folk local folkl Gods right eventually
all these Gods will be assimilated into
the Hindu hierarchy that's why you have
like a million gods in the Hindu
religion okay because they were all over
time assimilated into the hierarchy and
obviously
uh these gods are lesser Gods the higher
Gods the Holy
Trinity uh are Brahman
Gods okay all right so now's a chance
for uh Doug to to ask
his question about Buddhism before I
continue yeah
yeah go back to
the thec
yeah um so Way Way Back months ago you
you were talking about the pro
indoeuropean langues that's right right
and there's been a lot
ofical that's
right y you know there's been a similar
proc process looking at the different
Indian religions like Hinduism Buddism
jism and is there a certain common
denominator that perhaps could be faced
back to
okay great question okay so so what is
the IVC religion the portal religion
okay um I want to make an argument and
again it's uh speculation it's a very
strange argument and most Scholars
probably will not agree I think the
religion of the IBC is protab Buddhism
and the reason why
is if you look at
jism and you look at Proto Indo uh
Iranian the religion there are a lot of
similarities
okay and Proto zorm actually fits into
the larger Proto Indo European religion
framework when you look at
Hinduism you've got this strange idea
you a belief in karma Dharma
reincarnation
impermanence Brahma the Ultimate Reality
like like this is not part of the protal
Indo-European religion in anywhere
okay so but the same time Hinduism
Buddhism jism and Schism all share this
fun fundamental belief in the world that
this world is um a false reality it's a
reality created by our false beliefs and
if we learn to tame our emotions if we
learn to to see the underlying reality
governing all uh human structure then we
will be released from this world okay
now where would that come from that must
have come from the IVC because there
will be no other place also it explains
why these religions have such huge
followings in India right they don't
have any followings anywhere
else okay like Hinduism is basically
localized to uh India so it's chanism so
chanism so they are appealing to a
fundamental sense of the world among
Indians they're basically appealing to
Nostalgia right right and and where is
this noia from it must be from the
IVC okay so I would make that argument I
would I would I would believe I would
bet that if we were able to construct
the religion of the IVC the portal
religion we would see
a Proto Buddhism okay the beginnings of
Buddhism it would be very different okay
because Buddhism evolved over thousands
of years but the underlying assumptions
about the world um basically the idea of
Oneness
okay okay the idea of false
reality I think these two ideas would be
very apparent in the IVC as they are
apparent now in all four major Indian
religions Hinduism Buddhism jism and
jism okay do you want to continue
or no no no no no I'm finished but like
like you want to respond to to my
argument sense to okay and any are you
guys following along does this make
sense to you
guys in fact I would
argue that we as
humans fundamentally have Nostalgia for
these two ideas Oneness and false
reality okay because if you look at the
West okay if you look at us today there
are two ideas that are the most powerful
today in western civilization the first
idea is
Plato's allegory the
cave right the idea that we live in a
shallow
world and the truth is out there but we
have to seek it it's a very powerful
idea right and it's very similar by the
way to the ideas found in Hinduism and
Buddhism okay the Alor of the cave is
the first powerful idea and then the
second powerful idea is the idea of the
second
coming the return of Jesus because what
does the return of Jesus signify it
signifies Paradise on Earth it signifies
the destruction of our current reality
and the replacement of a new reality
that creates Oneness completeness and
wholeness on Earth
so in many
ways um this is very similar
to what the Indians are proposing as
well
so what this is saying is at a
fundamental
level everyone has Nostalgia for a
distant past okay and what is this the
distant pass the distant pass is the
idea of
animism so remember 10,000 years ago
20,000 years ago we were in the Ice Age
we were hunter gatherers and the way we
saw the world was very different from
the way we we see the world today okay
back then if you were a hunter gatherer
you could only think you you were the
same as the tree or as the animal okay
it's idea of Oneness we're no different
we're all part of the life cycle we're
all part of uh Mother Nature okay the
mother
goddess all right we also believe we
inhabit different realities at at the
same time right we live in this world
which is the material reality we we
we're also inhabiting the spiritual
reality as well and what we do
spiritually matters a lot more than what
we do M materially okay so we can
and kill animals as long as we pay the
proper respects to the animals we kill
as long as we um contribute spiritually
to the cycle cycle of life and death
okay so I think that's where Buddhism
comes from it comes from animism this
Buddhism this PO Buddhism became
reinforced and became much more concrete
because it was experiencing a reality in
Mesopotamia and Egypt that was abhorent
to the people experiencing okay War goes
against The Human Experience inequality
and Corruption and ways goes against The
Human Experience we fundamentally
believe this to be evil and
wrong
okay so that that is
my argument about the IVC any questions
any
comments you seem to
believe
are okay that's a great question um do I
believe that human nature is
fundamentally benevolent um I don't
believe human nature is is benevolent I
believe humans naturally see seek um a
spiritual understanding of the world I
think humans want to know why why are we
here where are we
going where do we come from okay we want
to know
why we also we're also curious we want
to explore the world okay so I think
trade is not a new invention I think
it's a very inherent thing to human
nature I think the idea idea of
globalization this was a globalized
world like 5,000 years ago okay
extremely sophisticated complex Global
globalized World so I think that's what
makes us fundamentally fundamentally
human okay and you can say this a good
thing or a bad thing and I would say
well it depends on the circumstance
right but I think what drives us is
humans is our
curiosity and our um our imagination
okay that's what I think being human is
and sometimes this is a good thing
sometimes this is a bad thing
okay sometimes in the IVC this will lead
to peace and egalitarianism but this
also is what drives the idea of the
second coming which is what's driving
the conflict in the Middle East today
okay so it depends on the context it
depends on the circumstance if if this
curiosity this imagination is channeled
effectively then I think that's a good
thing if it's
Channel opport opportunistically then
it's a a bad thing
okay okay but thank thanks for the
question any more
questions okay um so this end our Branch
age unit okay so we looked at the three
major Branch age civilizations Egypt
Mesopotamia and um
IVC next class we'll start the Bible
okay the Hebrew Bible
all right